I'm excited we're in Toronto Canada for
everybody tuning in and we're at the
sound heart convention we know what
happens when the battery goes dead phone
goes dead what about when the heart goes
dead we're seeing the consequences of
that depression is on the rise people
are becoming despondent falling into
despair suicide not only amongst adults
Bateen people going to the doctor for
this ache and that ache but he can't
write a prescription for the heart ache
but I'm gonna tell you who can when we
come back here on the D show don't go
anywhere we'll be right back
this is the theme this is the have you
found anymore
have you found a group of people who are
more inclined towards peace you know
they got us all over the news like we're
the you know barbarians who are all
about war and fighting and whatnot but
every time we greet each other you see
this peace going on have you ever met
any other group of people who are more
inclined towards this your comments I
wanted to kind of break the ice because
some people now when they tune in and as
soon as you mention Islam Muslims
they're tuning out so I wanted to let
them in to see kind of what we talked
about and one of the most important
things is the heart and I had mentioned
that people going to the doctor for all
sorts of aches but is it true that even
the doctor he cannot even though he's
writing a lot of prescriptions but can
he write a prescription for the
heartache definitely you know there's
doctors there are doctors who specialize
in the heart and they make the blood
flow in certain areas or they unclog
blood clots and so on and so forth well
some handle out you know getting to what
you were saying with the senem and the
piece and the heart right it's found
that it's absolutely amazed
because people feel that peace in their
hearts when they give sanim to each
other you send the blessings and peace
of Allah Subhan Allah to add upon that
person you walk by someone else and you
say assalamu alaykum you're literally
saying may the peace and blessings and
protection and safety of Allah be upon
you and so that person walking by
immediately their heart is like I'm calm
I'm peaceful this person just made a
nice prayer for me that may God protect
me and so that person feels peace at
heart beautiful we're at the sound heart
convention we talk about the heart I
opened up you know I gave an example you
know when the battery goes dead phone
goes dead
we need a recharge but now the
consequence of a dead heart so obviously
now I also mentioned the one who has
prescribed a prescription for the dead
heart so let's go take it to you and
what are your comments on about the
heart and the one who can't write a
prescription because we talked about
prescription lost pant Allah is the one
who created us he created us our Father
Adam and Saddam from dust and from him
all of his progeny so our bodies are
from the earth essentially but our soul
is from Allah span Tala and our bodies
we feed our bodies from what grows on
the earth but our soul is fed by what
Allah spatha has revealed the soul food
the food for the heart is in Revelation
like Allah Samantha says baka delica and
then I lay kuru ham in a Medina and
likewise we have revealed upon you O
Messenger of Allah a soul from our
command and that's the Quran that's
revelation
so al aswad Allah is the one who's
prescribing the cure for our hearts and
that's in the revelation that he sent in
the Quran and in the actions and the
statements of the problem excited and I
just jumped into it but let's go ahead
from the right to the left
shake a ditch shake down would shake
yeah Ibrahim like it was yesterday we
were at the peak we turn on peace and we
were at the peace conference overseas so
I'm excited to be with all you guys
thank you for being with me here on the
D show in Toronto Canada so let's
continue talking about the heart how
important is it to have a sound heart
and how can you get to having a sound
heart that you can describe one thing in
different ways and there's really three
important statements that Allah uses in
the plan to talk about the one thing
that we translate as heart or proverbial
heart so there's a word which is called
honey and Sunni alkyl group album in
Adelita and obey the heart was given the
description of the ever-shifting and it
goes from one side to the next
sometimes you have soaring high faith
and other times of plummets other times
of depression sometimes there's elation
and sometimes there's sadness
and that heart as it shifts from right
to left and from good to bad and from
Sunnah at times to be dire and from
happiness to discontent its control
ultimately is in the hand of Allah and
one of the most private drives we only
learn of this drive from the wives of
the Prophet omus element of the ilaha
and how allah she said that the habit of
the Prophet was to always ask Allah to
keep his heart steadfast ya Muhammad
alpha dog that bit can be Aladeen keep
my heart firm upon faith and it was this
private thing that he would hear him
stay in his home not out of doubt in his
mission but out of solidification for
what he really saw so that's the first
description the second is to add and the
word for add is it's like a proper
Arabic term for the heart there's also
the concept of subject at the chest
which
envelops and holds the heart and the
sutler you know it's that place where a
man injured and whenever Allah talks
about faith he says Shama Shama who sold
Rahul in Islam Allah has opened their
chest to the light of faith and it's a
meaning that the chest is open the heart
is full air is bare and that faith has
pierced it there's no you know nothing
that separates it one of the things that
the second term for ad it's about that
emotional heart and at times it's that
simple heart and Allah says in surah
that we saw in the summer when Basara
went to a good mood the hearing the site
you use and the malicious intentions and
movements of your heart all of that so
those three levels of hearts are really
really important in ascending from an
emotional state to one of solidifying
and bearing her a heart to people and to
Allah and third finding and knowing
ultimately that we need a lost support
to remain firm upon faith and love in
the face of tragedy and sinfulness and
adversity
someone who's tuning in and they've
heard this word love for the first time
how would you just in a tweet describe
Allah three you know the in the amount
of words you got two three six two three
sent so now someone who's just heard
this word for the first time how would
you describe a little bit difficult to
describe a law in a tweet because
there's so much to actually or so much
as attributed to a loss from Hannibal WA
Ta'ala but if I was to simplify it for
someone who simply came online and or
you know began watching and and and was
wondering what is Allah who is Allah
like we say there is no true God worthy
of worship except Allah right and Allah
is the Arabic term for God a deity that
we worship and it is an Arabic word and
so some Hanul Allah subhana WA Ta'ala
he is the one who created us and
everything in the universe and if I was
capable to elaborate just a little bit
you know to touch upon what really
affects our hearts with regards to a law
you know it's the depths of the night
when a person is going through extreme
hardship in their life and they're
stressed and depressed and you know
there's so much that's going on for them
and it keeps them awake in the middle of
the night like they wake up at 2 o'clock
having this nightmare and they don't
know what to do it themselves they can't
control themselves they're panicking a
typical panic or anxiety attack
and some kind of Allah as Muslims what
are we trained to do like we're trained
to go make Levu and pray two hundred at
that time right the night prayer and so
when you bow down and you put your head
down to the ground submitting to Allah I
think at that very moment we feel and
understand that there's nothing really
left for us on earth except to submit to
allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala and that that
coolness that calmness that patience the
you know the relief that a person feels
from the stress and anxiety that they
that might have startled their sleep is
no longer there because they fully and
truly submit to allah subhana wa ta'ala
and the and what tops it off is that
when they're literally making that
sujood and their head is down to the
ground and they're asking allah
subhanahu wa'ta'ala from the depths of
their heart allah is asking his angels
who is asking from me at that point in
time in the early stages of the morning
or the last part of the night and the
angels are saying so-and-so is asking
you so-and-so is asking you and he's
granting forgiveness and whatever that
person wants that's true submission
would that fit in at with that fit say
he is God the one and only the absolute
the eternal for me if I was gonna tweet
I would say Allah is who no one can be
Allah is no one can be and Allah was
before there was I was and Allah will be
when none shall be you ran out of
characters there you go deep deep we're
gonna take a break and we'll be right
back with more here on the D show don't
go anywhere
please subscribe to the D show follow us
on our official Facebook and Twitter
pages in the links below
please also help support the V show by
making a donation in the link below the
consequence of having a heart that's not
sound I had mentioned people becoming
despondent falling into despair
depression is on the rise suicide not
only amongst adults with teens is this
true what are your is this a consequence
now of not having a sound heart the just
wanted to point out something from the
Quran about this there's a story in
surah al-baqarah the second chapter of
the Quran where Musa Moses peace be upon
him goes and commands the Israelites to
sacrifice a a calf and they keep
refusing they keep putting it off to
keep slacking off they keep asking
questions about it what's the color of
this calf can you tell us more about it
ask your master what is it and
eventually they end up doing it and a
lot of poeple at the end of this whole
chapter says to mikasa to become
embodied Alec for here Cal hey Jarrah
after this your heart's addressing the
Israelites your hearts became harder
from Akkad Kulu
whom they became hard but he ecology
Chara as if there were rocks so the the
point is that our shadow pass were even
harder than rocks the point is that this
obey disobeying Allah spot Allah being
disconnected from revelation being
having these barriers between us and a
lost Pantelis book and then Sunnah of
the messenger saws on them by keeping by
keeping making these excuses and
deferring saying maybe I'll pray in all
pray there's still time I'll pray
there's still time before you know it
hands gone by just having that constant
attitude that makes a person's heart
very hard and in this case for the
Israelites it made it harder than Iraq
and a consequence of that was what
befell them afterwards so all of these
things that we see are consequences of a
hard heart the cause of it is disconnect
from the revelation or just deferring
slacking off from applying or following
the revelation we see people around us
that are at the higher echelon and
people look up to them people such as
Robin Williams for instance who not too
long ago committed suicide and you have
many people following his footsteps but
they have all the money they have the
status they have the fame what seems to
be the problem here zu ihnen in SEO
Boosh hwacha Mina and Nyssa a well Benny
Noel Kahn ethereal makan 40 min and very
well Phil ba mo controller you know very
well Phil ba basically wealth called
silver wealth different things that we
have and Allah span wa ta'ala tells us
that he gives us these things and he
beautified the world he beautified this
dunya for us with all of these things
that he mentioned and from amongst it is
that wealth now subhanAllah when a
person acquires wealth you'll notice
that some people who gain so much wealth
their lives are you know being
broadcasted to the entire world and
children and youth want to be like that
they want to have the bends they want to
have the bling-bling and all that
fashion and everything but somehow Allah
what what they don't see is what happens
when all the cameras close at the end of
the day and that person goes to sleep
and stops tweeting and is no longer on
Facebook and so on and so forth
what's the condition of that person's
life like they might be extremely lonely
they might be suffering from you know
not having a social life and so on and
so forth so that wealth doesn't really
bring happiness now almost penlight
Allah tells us that he beautified the
world with these things for us that
doesn't mean that we should not be
wealthy people that doesn't mean that we
have to give up wealth rather allah
subhana wa ta'ala is telling us to use
that wealth correctly so we're told how
to use wealth that you gain wealth in
one hand you spend it in the other hand
you're not paying attention to it
meaning you get wealth you spend wealth
and it never gets to your heart it
remains in your hand use it as a tool to
get through life and to enjoy the
bounties and blessings that are lost pan
without has given us so you can either
use the wealth positively and get to
Jannah or you can use that wealth in a
way that could actually make you more
depressed because you are filling your
life like share adage mentioned you know
there's food for the body and food for
the soul and when you use all that money
on your body but you're not filling your
soul or your heart with the connection
with allah subhana wa ta'ala
it doesn't matter how much money you
have there is a Japanese lady
it was just recent in news she had won
the first place for being the oldest
woman at a hundred and seventeen years
of age know if anybody read this and it
was interesting when they had asked her
what was it about her life now that she
can attribute her longevity and she said
this is quoting her that I put God first
and I was good with the people so we see
now can we attribute and they've done
some studies I want you to comment on
this people who do put the Creator first
you know they live less of a stress-free
life I mean we all have tribulations
that we go through but when we hold on
to the Rope of God
now we somehow seem to not fall deep
down into despondence and despair we
seem to get out but on the flip side
people who don't have this rope that
they hold down to this connection with
their maker what happens I think you
know it's a telling example that when
one feels connected to the greater be to
the one who is in all control it kind of
releases a lot of the stress that we
have on our mind and you know in our
heart it's okay to not seek to control
everything and one of the downfalls I
think of many societies and our
communities is that we live in a way
where we want to micromanage and control
every single aspect of our life and
we're not just willing to just give
something up to God and just say you
know cut door allaha masha'Allah this is
something that God you know has
determined for me that I must endure and
overcome in that lillahi wa inna ilayhi
roger own we you know we all belong to
God we to him we will eventually return
and you know the prophets of allah wahda
he will send them you know the final
moments of his life were a sure sign
that all of us will experience tragedy
and one of the things about the death of
the Prophet SAW I said him that we don't
think enough of sallallahu salem's is
the impact it had on those who lived
with him you know there were people who
would be given a new child you know and
he would look at his child just a few
days or months or years after the death
of the Prophet and instead of feeling
absolute joy at this new gift to his
life he would be saddened and he would
say I wish Muhammad had seen this child
I wish rasulullah sallallahu alayhi
wasallam had been here to bless this
child make your art for him so you know
there was a sense of in their joy they
felt his loss and in their tragedy you
know someone dies in your family you
would say I wish they had died earlier
in the time when the Prophet was here
somewhere
and for us as Muslims we really really
really to reconnect our life and realign
it with that muhabba of rasulullah
sallallahu alayhi wasallam it doesn't
surprise me that someone would have
longevity of life because they have
trust in other than themselves and that
they have aim and faith in other than
their strength and for all of us the
strength we have the successes we have
the education that we have there are
moments in life where that will all fail
us and all that is left as a lot
dramatizes in the Quran hadith Iraqi boy
feel full when they ride on the ship and
the waves begin to play there I will
laugh everyone at that moment says my
god help me and sometimes we just need
to say Ya Allah
I submit to you just submit it submit is
isn't is what Moses did and Jesus did
and Abraham did they are submitted to
the will of God it's all about giving
yourself completely to the true power
and you know the names and the
attributes of God tell us about him you
know when you spoke about a law and and
you know the the proper name of God the
Lord the God the only one worthy of
worship but of his names and attributes
things that describe him is al hardan
the one who has all ability alka we the
one who none can have strength except
from his strength
you know the arose up the source of all
providence and blessing right so the
this totality of focusing our self in a
God centric way is empowering and this
is the way of all the messengers the
prophets that God Almighty sent because
it was the call of everyone that
preceded all of them met all of them
from the beginning of Adam until the end
of humanity
now speaking about the last final
message of how Muhammad peace and
blessings be upon him who had mentioned
in a authentic tradition can you comment
on this because it goes with what we're
talking about the heart he said there's
a more so in the body that if it's sound
the whole body will be sound of his
corrupt
the whole body will be corrupt can you
comment on this then he said that that
morsel is the heart heart to heart now
there is
I just wanted to the eye on the heart
speaking of the heart and having a sound
heart the profits awesome mentioned a
narration in which he mentions there's a
man who lost his child a young child an
infant and a lot he actually describes
the conversation that takes place
between Allah and the angels and the
lost matalava Slee knows exactly what
happened but this conversation is
described by the proper system so that
we can learn something from it and take
away a very important lesson he
describes that this Allah Allah Samantha
says to the Angels that you took the
soul of the infant of my slave the angel
said yes we did that was what was
commanded to us he asked did you take
away the apple of his eye kabaah Tom Sam
errata for Adi he the fruit of his heart
is literal translation the better
translation would be the apple of his
eye the joy of his life and they say the
Angels say yes the mother call her Abdi
what did my slave say when this tragedy
happened the angel said hamanaka was
stargell he praised you and he said in
ala llahi were in Ilayaraja rule be to
Allah we are we belong to Allah and we
will return to Allah and then Allah
father said build a house in Jannah for
the slave and call it the house of
praise the point is that this man
anonymous not named in this narration
this could be anybody this could be
anybody in the crowd anybody who's
listening
anybody who suffered this incredible
loss this could be any of those people
this is a person who is demonstrating
what it means to have a sound heart that
they have this connection with a
hospital even in the most difficult time
in their life when they've just lost
their child they're still able to
remember Allah and not just remember
Allah thank Allah and remind themselves
that we are in fact we belong to Allah
and we will eventually return to Him
those the
those actions at the strike of the most
difficult calamity that shows the true
soundness of the heart we're talking
about having a sound the sound heart at
the sound heart convention in Toronto
Canada
we'll be right back down below anyway
please subscribe to the diva follow us
on our official Facebook and Twitter
pages in the links below
please also help support the V show by
making a donation in the link below